in this morning's final reporters
notebook we turn to all of you
here in the studio in the building and
CBS News bureaus all over the world and
to you our audience at home usually you
write essays to get into things college
a job an idea this is an essay on the
way out what your name is I'm a transfer
student here after 17 months as
co-anchor of CBS this morning
I'm leaving the program to go to 60
minutes the ultimate exit essay isn't
eulogy but I come not to bury but to
praise a good day
contains meaning joy and love meaning
here is given to us by the news cycle
yeah asking about the mod investigation
but personal meaning in this job comes
from being in the company of so many
people working all together under
tremendous pressure and high stakes to
untangle the news and tell stories well
you have no idea of the logistical
challenges mr. president you are 94 it
is nearly 94 degrees outside what are
you doing here two possums once started
fighting on the roof of a building where
we were trying to hold a focus group
shortly before an interview with Theresa
May they switched the location 120 miles
south wasn't that great
the days are long and broken planes and
train tunnels filled with water and
breaking news all mock our plans
[Music]
despite that the joy in this show is
obvious why I oughta give us the bad
news line good morning basically
introduction Johnny we have a license to
interview politicians Howard Schultz has
now said he would not run as an
independent if the Democrats nominated
Davis actors you say action is my to ask
them anything we want
are you a hoarder John Bryan no no I use
everything I steal and we have great fun
around the plexiglass table we know how
lucky I did actually make some bedazzled
black t-shirts that say I love Taylor
Swift and I might have an extra one in
your eye you have a bedazzler you drop
some I drop the kid at the top of my pen
but don't want me to get it one of the
time 100 Gail do any of that thank you
though sometimes my jokes seem only to
be for myself welcome back to dad jokes
central those talons are really sharp
Mariners are usually worried about
albatrosses but that's another story
even the crews like roller owned of
appreciation that's what it is actually
there was no brownie which is crickets
John Dickerson
[Music]
and now to the love well--that's
everywhere everyone who surrounds us
during the two hours that we're on the
air or that works in the offices above
or in the Edit Bay's below they build
the stage on which we get to dance and
without which we would collapse if those
of you out there feel like you're a part
of a community it's because you are
hello television audience so thanks for
letting me join in it's anchor away my
friends I'll be back again someday
just in a different chair you sound
pretty good oh well all I did was just
grow up listening to John Wright you
sound pretty good what I love is how you
pay tribute to the crew and the team
that works with us to put this team
together and you look at what you've
done John you've done a lot here well
you know everything that they do so it's
of course you and also to Keira and
Claire for putting that together and Wes
and Craig they did an amazing job on
that peel so you've done an amazing job
we're saying anchor away but it's really
anchored way across the street - bigger
- bigger and better sixty minutes that's
that is no joke like ya know I'm
thrilled to go there but I'm also
thrilled to have been here that - before
you leave though could we bring out the
certificate for John's mani-pedi we want
you to look good this is from everybody
everybody signed in all the sizes went
wide who knows about guitars and Liza
Donnelly did this carat Wow so this is a
good guitar we wanted to give you a
Martin guitar John because Martin Odum
our classic American guitar